We're not just going to learn about absolute value. We'll also going to learn
about their equations and inequalities. We learn that the absolute value of a
number represents the distance from zero. So, the distance of some unknown
number must be 7. Well, I can't be 7 units away on my current number line, let's
extend it. This means that variable d could be 7 units to the left of 0, or 7
units to the right of zero. The Algebra tells us that d could be at negative 7,
or d could be at positive 7. This is why when we solve absolute value equations,
you'll often see us split it into two equations, one with a positive answer, and
one with a negative. Because remember, our distance from zero could be to the
right or to the left. The negative represents the left. But keep in mind, this
distance is still positive. Only the value of d or the location, is negative.